ever dream that you and your best bro of
all time were lobsters GQ as the in on
Garrett and Quinn your most stylish best
bros of all time and we're counting down
the top 5 moments from our favorite
crustaceans number five when Garrett and
Quinn debate the meaning of sexy casual
formal well I'm on it I'm full sexy
casual right now you're wearing a
varsity jacket and a shirt that looks
like a dress from eileen fisher exactly
sexy casual this is a saint laurent
varsity jacket but what about you what
do you wear like wearing a full-on tux
so I mean Texans not casual it is when
it's my casual tux midnight blue number
four have you ever found a roommates
fingernail clippings gross right well
imagine if you molted bro what are you
doing stop messing up my exoskeletons
why why would you keep your exoskeletons
after your mole this is gonna sound like
super weird but sometimes later night I
put them on and I go out and I try to
fight crime fight you fight crime like
my batsuit scare and I'm Ben Affleck
number three when garrett quinn and an
otter barista one-up each other over the
best way to prepare coffee okay thank
you Quinn and all actually i got this
gear he'll have an el salv I thought
like a choice bro trust me you're not
ready for a qualm definitely stick feel
south training which is right you're not
I'm the one who introduced you to pour
over but how the student has become the
teacher I copy knowledge is way past
rate and the teachers carrington your
while the student is like barely skating
by seeing a tutor number two attending
your boss's barbecue bro you said and I
quote this is going to be the Coachella
of office part I said quote it will be a
pretty fun BB yeah but I try to rewrite
everything that you say in my head while
you're talking to MIT to make it more
interesting so I'm not just like
constantly bored to death and number one
has got to go to when we witnessed the
possible demise of our fav dudes warning
major spoilers bro we got a problem
Garrett they're literally no problems in
the world we should get out on top like
right now bro that is a huge negative
water is way too hot I don't want to say
the B word Gary do not say boiling
you're actually boiling you are being
dramatic what is hotter
water for those two smoking hot babes
mind you one of them is Australian Jeff
gonna leave the water row they told us
to wait here do not blow this for me oh
oh no Quinn Quinn Quinn like my arm my
arm is numb like when Derek your banana
my link hotels notes keep our heads ah
ah ok I can't see out of my left eye ah
no I right I can't see anything I'm
blind I'm totally blind I'm just I'm
gonna I'm gonna try to float my body
towards the edge of the tub of steak I'm
glad to see you to keep backing on these
go Quinn I've lost equilibrium oh there
goes me too if this reminds you of your
bro send it to him stat and watch out
for season two of gentlemen lobsters
coming soon to video GQ com